hey I just my name is Christopher Garron
burger and I've David and Karen have
gotten me involved in this coming here
to film courage and the one thing I like
about it I mean it seems like
independent films is like the basis of
acting and there's not a time that I
don't come by here what I don't I don't
learn anything that's it that's gonna
that's going to help me as a as an actor
not only an actor but you know a lot of
these these films I mean they're just a
small ideas that just means so much and
you can really you can really you can
really learn a lot and basically about
them you know like tonight there was a
it was called one hour fantasy girl and
it was it was a film about some
basically a girl that was that was
homeless and has this uh you know she
runs this one our fantasy girl where
there's you know no sex but anything
else goes and it was it was interesting
and like a human life piece that you
would never really seen the big theatre
and then for me I mean that's I mean
it's great to see stuff like that it's
just stuff that really makes you think I
mean blowing up stuff the big budget
stuff as always as always nice but when
when you have like small budget stuff
that relies a lot on the story a lot of
time to get a lot so